reservations required to head up to
mount charleston on this christmas day
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
went up to the lodge and
talked to people excited about the
holiday and the new year
we're up here at mount charleston lodge
where reservations are completely booked
but that's not stopping people from
enjoying the fresh air on this christmas
day
while the snow was light that didn't
stop people from driving up to kyle
canyon for the holiday
and enjoying the brisk air many people
walking around with their dogs
masks on taking pictures and admiring
the views
the mount charleston lodge quickly
reached full capacity as they had
breakfast with santa and mrs claus
and then transitioned into lunch and
dinner a lot of people disappointed that
they weren't able to dine in
but took advantage of the mild weather
to do some outdoor exploring
look at the weather out here there's a
bit of snow up here the restaurant is
unfortunately
booked but that's okay i think we're
going to go for a little hike right now
because it's so beautiful we didn't
think ahead to make a reservation
so we're not going to be able to go in
unfortunately but we'll still get to
have our christmas spirit right here on
mount charleston down the road a bit
from the lodge people were seen enjoying
the snow
tubing and sledding traffic picked up
around 1 p.m but no major congestion and
coming up at six we'll talk to the
general manager here at mount
charleston lodge about their
expectations for today along with what
they're serving for christmas dinner
reporting from mount charleston madison
kimbrough 8 news now